some of them are in plain clothes
while others
are in military uniform
they just jump over the fence they came
there they beat up my god
the horrors of my gardeners
yeah we found the ugandan presidential
candidate
bobby wine anxiously examining his
property
outside the capital kampala the 38 year
old
said members of the military had
surrounded his house
and beaten up his guard at the garden
gate
we found five men in uniform with
automatic weapons
confronted by our party a soldier picked
up his machine gun
and aimed it at us
[Applause]
in an act of collective fear we ran for
cover
the pop star turned politician said he'd
spent the day at home
awaiting the results in uganda's general
election
you can see them they're right there
you know i asked him what he thought was
going on
i don't know why they are
doing this but i know
that they are targeting my life
i know that they're trying to
normalize such actions this is
in your view this is the end of it you
expect more
from the authorities i don't know i
think
i'm i'm convinced they
can do the worst as you can see while we
have soldiers
in military uniform we have those
individuals that you've seen there
who are carrying you know
ak-47 and then plane closes
it looked like a clear attempt at
intimidation
although a military spokesman said they
were only trying to protect
the opposition leader are you not scared
the presidential campaign has been a
difficult experience for the 38 year old
and he says work produced by journalists
has helped to keep him safe
but the authorities are getting very
close to this popular politician
john sparks sky news kampala